good afternoon everyone my name is
researcher Miller and the SCP were going
to be studying today is scp-1162-j class
Euclid special containment procedures
scp-1162-j
are to be stored in a three by three by
three meter chamber at site 1167 - -
each is to be kept in a locked case
equipped with a security camera sight
1167 - one is to be staffed by two
security personnel at all times
disguised as forest rangers Exploration
temporarily suspended any anomalous
materials or items found at site 1167 -
- are to be studied and cleared by dr.
Stinson before being brought into
contact with sep11 67 description
scp-1162-j 20 centimeters tall
consisting of a control unit attached to
an articulated arm and a flat base
subjects components are of unknown
manufacture and utilize an advanced
power source that has not required
charging at any point during containment
SCP 1167 was discovered by spelunkers in
and delivered to local authorities who
passed it on to foundation personnel
site 1167 - one has been established at
the discovery location scp-1162-j
Smith's arm to gradually propel the
control unit forward left alone SCP 1167
will attempt to navigate outside of any
containing structure at which point it
will adopt a heading towards 23 point 56
South 68 point 16 West changing
direction only to avoid obstacles
SCP 1167 is capable of synthesized
speech but does not respond to questions
SCP 1167 continually repeats the
following message in 124 languages
including 8 dead languages and 15 which
have not been identified and the
following message is as follows
broadcast alert recovery failed initiate
retreat and seek reinforcements alert
alert if a nearby person speaks
approximately five full sentences of a
specific language SCP 1167 will use that
language exclusively until the person
leaves the immediate area between each
repetition scp-1162-j is I dent achill
each time but has not yielded any
meaningful information SCP 1167 was
delivered to multiple testing sites and
placed on the ground to track movement
over 100 meters this information was
used to triangulate the subjects
possible destination a research team was
sent to the location which is in the
vicinity of the matura qui crater in
Chile an initial survey yielded no
anomalous discoveries scp-1162-j step on
the ground as CP 1167 scanned the
environment before speaking SCP 1167
said the following scan complete
conveyance missing maintained location
and await reinforcements site 1167 - -
has been established for further study
and evacuation of the target location
several anomalous objects have been
located and presented to scp-1162-j
addendum scp-1162-j 220 meters northeast
of site 11 67 - 2 5 meters below ground
the wrist is cleanly severed as CP 11 67
reaction scan complete
missing component relocated retained for
repair SCP 1167 - - unnatural scarring
of a section of bedrock measuring 150
meters by 1 meter discovered one
kilometer north east of site 11 67 - 2 8
meters below ground sample acquired SCP
1167 reaction scan complete archived
status report weapon modification
ineffective continued pursuit sep11 67 -
3 a non-functioning control unit similar
to sep11 67 - the arm or base recovered
during an exploration of the cave system
under site 11 67 - 1 4 members of the
exploration team remained missing
scp-1162-j
unit leader terminated target lost
initiate retreat
okay this concludes your lecture for
today thank you very much for listening
you are all dismissed goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to Andre Bessette thank you very much
Sean Barie your pledge is very much
appreciated if you would like to know
how you can get a personalized thankee
at the end of each of my videos as well
as some other really cool stuff as well
go to patreon.com/scishow
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]